hey everyone what is up this is brian
also known as sketch across the
community and we are coming to you live
today
from 343 industries here in redmond
washington and let me just say it feels
great to be back i feel like today has
been a long time coming i'm excited to
finally kick this off i know you all are
so welcome to today's live stream and we
are going to dive into
this weekend's upcoming halo infinite
tech
preview now before we get going just
want to give you guys a little bit of
context for what we're going to cover
today
we're going to have a couple guests
rotate through we're going to dive right
into the same exact build that halo
insiders will get their hands on
starting tomorrow
we are live so all the same known issues
that we're aware of in this tech preview
that's work in progress
are also in this build today so who
knows what's going to happen uh
hopefully everything goes smoothly but
just ask everyone to bear with us also
i've kind of been in my house in the
quarantine for about two years if you
can't tell so
we might be a little bit rusty but we're
going to have a lot of fun today we got
a lot of cool stuff to talk about and
show so to kick things off
i want to introduce sam hanshaw producer
on the live team
sam welcome thanks it's good to be here
i'm ready to have some fun and
introduce our fans to our first tech
preview so let's let's sort of start by
setting a little bit of context and i
know folks are eager to see
and see stuff and dive in we're going to
get to that in a few minutes but
just let's kind of start at the highest
level we talk about fighting a lot we
talk about tech previews a lot
kind of what do we want our viewers and
our insiders to know like what do we
mean like what is the context for what
this really is
sure so i think that calling it a tech
preview
that encapsulates it we're testing our
technology here
we're looking to get players into games
we're looking to
make sure that the servers are up and
running well
and that we can support everything with
our service infrastructure
obviously we also want people to have
fun while doing it and
we need to get feedback on the breadth
of hardware that we know is out there
you know we can't test on every
combination of uh
hardware people have for their pcs but
we know that the folks at home can
and so we need your help to do that and
this is uh
safe to say this will be the biggest
scale test that we've been able to do to
date we're talking
hundreds of thousands of halo insiders
have been invited
to participate this weekend and
obviously we've been
hard at work testing we've done smaller
scale flights to lead up to this point
but
like what does that process look like
like what have we what's had to happen
to get us to where we are today
sure uh quite a bit been some hurdles
along the way for sure
um we cut the we cut this branch about
two months ago and that's when we
started with a lot of the
testing for it and kind of targeted bug
fixes towards getting a stable product
to have out today for tech preview
now it's two months old it's still got
some bugs
we know that we've got a robust
known issues list for folks to be
prepared before they dive in
and we expect you to hit some new bugs
that we haven't seen
and that's part of what we're excited
about because we need your help to
find these bugs and so we can see how
they reproduce
and fix them internally but yeah it's
been about two months of testing
fixing and play testing to get to this
and if i really want to roll it back
even further it's safe to say that you
know we've been flighting as kind of a
process which by the way
for those that aren't familiar because
not everybody uses the same jargon out
there right when we talk about flighting
it's really the process of putting out
kind of iterative pre-release software
to a target audience with some expected
goals to go after
we put the build out it tests we get the
feedback
and we act on that feedback and sort of
move on to the next one so
safe to say we've been doing this for
quite some time at a much smaller scale
so this is not the first time we've put
the game in the hands of
civilians so to speak um so we've been
getting feedback all along i just kind
of wanted to bring that point up this is
not
it's not like we've just been heads down
this is our first time sharing our baby
with the world we've had a small group
of
various insider private flights user
research so all these inputs have been a
critical part of development really
since the beginning
um certainly but now we're opening the
floodgates to get all sorts of new
perspectives and
i think critically fresh eyes brand new
perspectives yeah absolutely fresh eyes
fresh hardware
like everything that we could ask for
it's coming from the hundreds of
thousands of people
who are going to be playing this weekend
so before we move on i also just want to
comment on you know
if if your twitter feed's like mine the
invite started rolling out yesterday
about 5 p.m to eligible insiders uh
it's been kind of a whirlwind of
emotions i'm sure for many people
sending out hundreds of thousands of
emails it turns out takes a lot of time
there were people as of an hour or two
ago i'm seeing are just now receiving
their emails so
i think my message to everyone is you
know not everyone will get in this this
particular tech preview on this flight
and
we knew that was going to be the case
because you know we need to
incrementally grow we don't want to we
sort of want to walk before we run right
um but i do want to make sure people
know that there will be future
opportunities right
this is not the only tech preview that
we've planned between now and launch
that's correct
um this is the first and probably the
smallest
so as we grow and over the coming months
as we put out
new builds with additional features
they're each going to have a larger and
larger audience as we head towards
launch
so just really critically if you want to
be a participant in a future tech
preview or flight please head to
haloinsider.com
anyone can opt in at any point make sure
your profile is completed we'd love to
get more and more people in for future
flights as sam mentioned so
sam maybe now let's shift gears a little
bit i think one of the really cool and
ambitious aspects of this project
is kind of the breadth of platforms that
we're going to support right now i mean
we
not only is our multiplayer experience
free to play but cross play i mean we
are
really truly going to where our players
are regardless of platform
yeah and this tech preview is no
exception
we're going to be fighting this tech
preview on
all the platforms we intend to uh ship
with at launch
so you're going to be able to play on
anything in the xbox one family
the series x and series s and we're
going to be going out to of
as i said before a variety of pc
hardware and all of that's going to be
cross play
and the pc by the way also on steam
which we know a lot of fans were excited
about i think for the purpose of this
tech preview
we're only on steam for pc but obviously
for launch that won't be the only means
of playing our game
um now one thing we did want to know i
think sam at a high level safe to say
that
the experience that we're going to put
out in this tech preview specifically on
each of these platforms when it comes to
like fidelity and performance
safe to say that what's in the preview
today is not necessarily indicative of
our targets when we launch this game
yeah that's correct so performance is
something that we're working on
week after week and as i said before
this is a build that's about two months
old so we cut this from main
two months ago to work on it and a lot
of the performance work that goes in
wasn't appropriate to bring over to this
branch because performance work
can often create instability we want to
keep this as stable as possible
when we launch it to you all so this
build about two months behind in terms
of performance
and obviously there's more one way to go
before we launch
later this year and i i would assume the
data we get from this tech preview will
be really valuable as we continue to
sort of make sure we're supporting the
widest breadth of pc configurations for
example and
really the team's goal is to deliver a
really solid performance good looking
experience catered to every platform
that we support
exactly i couldn't set it better myself
so speaking of that i know people are
eager to see some stuff
it's kind of cool really if you think
about it life to date we've only ever
shown halo infinite running on pc
and we're going to do that here live
today in a little bit we're going to
show some stuff off but
this is going to be the first time
people can see what the game looks like
running on an
actual xbox hardware so uh prior to the
stream we were able to put together a
little bit of gameplay capture
and i'd like to give folks a glimpse at
this is going to be a halo infinite
multiplayer match
recorded i believe last week here in the
studio
just to give people a sense of this is
the game as it currently stands in this
build
running on an xbox one so i'm going to
give a shout out to joshua here behind
the scenes he's running production for
the live stream
josh if you want to cue that up i think
people are really eager to see some
gameplay
let's take a look let's see how this
game is looking currently on xbox one
sporting down
sam clearly we're looking at a little
slayer match here on bazaar
one of our new maps there's a lot to
take in i'm sure for viewers who are
just
seeing a lot of stuff for the first time
here yeah i can't i can't remember
if we've shown things like the false car
line being used i think it was weekly
shown in the multiplayer trailer and i
think this is the first time we've shown
first person view of someone walking
around in bazaar
i think it has we're also right now kind
of getting a look at the friend info
system that we've discussed in some of
our blogs in the past this is
kind of moving away from forcing players
into red and blue allows us to kind of
maintain that unique armor customization
that's become a
greater focal point for halo infinite
yeah and i think this is a this is a
pretty good example of that and i think
you're really seeing those colors pop
out on the xbox one hardware that's
great
i think i just noticed a custom skin
applied to that ar there that we saw
briefly
i missed it unfortunately i do love that
oh yeah
i love the ar skins it's kind of nice
being able to customize your starting
weapon
it's the one you're going to see most
often so i like to have mine
uh now internally from a development
playtest perspective i mean obviously
we've got the teams focusing on all
platforms and all builds and safe to say
that that we've got
folks truly getting sweaty on durango on
xbox series x and s
and low me medium and high pc specs as
well right
yeah so obviously as i said before we
can't cover
every pc spec out there but we try to
have a good range within our testing
and we have folks playing on xbox ones
regularly myself included
i try and play test on xbox one as much
as possible
so because it's a really important thing
for us to support make sure it's looking
good
yeah it really it really is awesome that
we're able to kind of
bring that audience forward with us
right and we know there's there's
obviously a large amount of xbox one
players out there especially
as you know frankly some people i think
are still eager to acquire a new console
and
with some of the supply chain issues
that have come around during the
pandemic
not necessarily easy for everyone so
you know thankfully i'm not one of the
engineers i can't imagine it's
necessarily a trivial undertaking to be
able to scale so so smartly across
different hardware but
i gotta say shaping up super super nice
and really looking forward to getting
some feedback from xbox one players
after this weekend yeah absolutely
so that's i think that's going to wrap
up that clip that we have now we're
going to show a little more game play
here in a bit
um we're going to have tom french our
multiplayer associate creative director
join us we have another match from xbox
series x that we're going to get into
but once this wraps up we're going to
jump back over to the build and we're
going to look through this real flight
build here
by the way i i heard you're a real
neither fan is that true
that is true i i love the needle i find
i think it's one of the most unique
weapons we have in halo
and i've loved every expression of it
hasn't always been the most powerful gun
in the game but it's always been
interesting to use it it feels like it
shreds in this game at least in our play
test right
yes it's do not sleep on the kneeler
this weekend i'll just say that
yeah especially like against bots like
they don't know how to deal with it
so yeah he's real good against them you
mentioned bots
we'll talk about that a little bit more
a little bit later in the show today
when tom joins us um
why don't we sort of pivot back now to
the real build which i'm sure people are
really eager to see
and i thought maybe we just kind of
helped give our players who are going to
be a part of the tech preview just kind
of give them the lay of the land a
little bit
show them what they can expect and and
what that's going to look like so josh
maybe if you want to
cut to uh we'll go to my feed i reckon
and we can
sort of take a look at
our lobby space i guess you know what do
we what is the official term for this
space that we're going to feed into once
josh is able to kind of hit that switch
there we go
so this is it right this is our tech
preview build we're looking at it right
now live
yep this is the essentially the menu
that you're gonna hit as soon as you
boot up so um you can see like the
multiplayer academy options there if you
hit
start you can get into our main settings
and there's a few settings i think we
want to we want to show let's take a
look i mean
no i like settings no one's ever seen
these settings in detail before so we'll
just we'll kind of take a look here so
um we want to make sure obviously
players understand and like first thing
you should do if you're going to be in
the tech preview this week and probably
just kind of get acclimated
tweak your settings to your liking just
make sure that things are sort of the
way you want them if you will so
i think you know i'll just quickly
scroll through i'm not going to speak to
every one of these i think we'll be here
all afternoon but
i think you're going to find a lot of um
sort of what you'd expect to find
in some regards you know hold the sprint
if i want to do that i can kind of
really dial in my sensitivity and all
that
i'm pretty casual so i kind of tend to
just run default in a lot of cases i'm
not afraid to admit that
[Music]
yeah i think that i've never gotten into
all the zoom sensitivity settings but
i'm just worried that i would get myself
into a state where i would just never
land a shot again or who knows maybe
i would suddenly sort of evolve to the
next level um now keyboard and mouse
players uh on pc
and also i believe console now supports
uh pc
mouse and keyboard as well excuse me
couple things here they might want to
look at that's pretty interesting if we
can get down
to it is the fact that you know triple
keybinds you can you have a lot of
flexibility here and how you want to set
up your keys
i want to give a shout out you know as
all the work that happened over the last
couple years to update mcc and bring
that to pc and then all the fantastic
work by the pub team
you know being able to have triple
keybinds was super important to the pc
community that was great feedback that
we heard and
that's a good example of just one of
taking those learnings and kind of that
experience and bringing it over to the
infinite side
yeah i think we owe a great debt to all
the work that mcc and the publishing
team
has done with diving in like feet first
into
the pc environment and getting us ready
for this you know i'll hover on this one
for a minute because i'm pretty sure i
haven't been able to do this before in
the game have i been able to actually
just straight up drop my weapon for a
teammate before
nothing i know of and honestly it's been
it's been quite fun to use
uh especially when you're playing with
like some less experienced players
you can just secure rockets for them and
then hand it over to them
you know they get to play around with a
power weapon that they might not
normally have gotten
so dare we say maybe this is the end of
betraying your teammates to take sniper
yeah now you just got to extort them i
guess possibly cool so a whole bunch of
stuff here um you know this is something
else that we um
i think was mentioned in one of our
employee spotlight blogs but
um marking this is also a new element
to halo games yeah and i thought you've
been really happy with the marking
system
so if you're on pc it is super easy just
to mock everyone you see
and the game rewards you for you
actually get points you get a mock
assist if someone kills someone who
you've marked
and stacks with your normal assist
points and i believe there's a medal you
can earn
there is marking enough people who get
killed
so i'll just kind of scroll through here
quickly so we don't totally get
inundated in settings but it just goes
on and on and on so let me go over here
to video as well
something else i just kind of want to
point out which by the way i do not that
is
criminal for me to be on a fov of only
70 but
you know we heard i think this has
always been something halo fans have
wanted we we know and everyone knows the
fov
really does have a dynamic impact on
your experience in terms of
not only just your vision but the
sensation of movement and speed all
those things are greatly impacted so
pretty awesome to me that on day one we
already have a field of view slider and
this is going to be available on
i think on multiple platforms it's not a
pc only feature that's correct yeah
i mean what's your preference i kind of
generally like to kick it up here maybe
in the 90 to 100 range
i mean we can go what all the way up to
120 if we really wanted to
yeah i usually like to kick it in 95 to
100 all right well
i'll split the difference we'll go 95
there but yeah just kind of go through
here
lots of different nuanced graphical
settings to really allow people to
custom tailor based on
you know their own personal preferences
what's most important to them on their
pc hardware
um if i didn't mention that if it's not
clear we are playing on pc here
currently so
you know you will not have the full
breadth of all these options necessarily
on every platform
but clearly for pc it makes the most
sense i thought this is pretty cool too
being able to sort of opt in or opt out
of something that we call speed lines so
when you're sprinting in the game we
have some cool visual effects that help
sort of really convey that sense of
increased speed but if i don't like it i
can just turn it off yeah i think the
the fact that we've got so many settings
that are tailored so that you can fully
immerse yourself
or if you're looking for a stripped down
experience if you don't want that
you can turn it off same thing goes of
course lots of audio customization here
um i want to make sure people are aware
of like things like subtitles you can
turn those off and on if you want to
i did want to call this out as well i
know you and i were talking earlier
about this but
just a little bit of a public service
announcement for anyone playing this
weekend in the tech preview
by default currently in this build your
mic is just set to full open full hot so
some people might like that some people
may not personally i was kind of caught
by surprise when i was saying a bunch of
stuff in a game and i thought it was
private
so i just wanted to pass that my
learnings on to you so no one gets kind
of caught
maybe in a precarious situation there um
so yeah a lot of different options here
including spartan chatter we'll hear a
little bit more of that
when we roll some more footage and then
the last thing i thought would be kind
of cool to really point out we've talked
about this a little bit briefly in some
of our blogs but
we have this new system that we're
calling friend info right which
in order to really support and embrace
our goals and our aspirations about
leaning more into player expression and
having a lot more cool ways to customize
your own spartan and your own spartan
journey
it just didn't really work anymore to
force everyone into a
default red or blue model right right
and and so by default we have red and
blue outlines
but for accessibility purposes we know
the various people can't see
in certain shades so we've got a wide
array of colors that you can choose for
both enemies
and friends and you can also customize
uh the focus in your fire team
to be another unique color yeah it's it
is really flexible really cool i also
personally being able like being able to
sort of if i want to go old school and
display a full gamer tag above someone's
head i could do that
also helps me sometimes when i'm
personally just trying to register a
friend from foe
um and then you know i should call this
out you'll see this in the in the ui
menu here the theater will not be
included in the tech preview so we won't
have that experience the theater is
coming back though so
um and you know event timeline is a
brand new feature we'll talk a little
bit more about that later but
you could probably surmise what that
might mean in the context of the theater
um and this is pretty crazy too weapon
offsets so
people want to be able to move that
stuff around i guess yeah
i know i know i know people who like to
get uh that's like different gameplay
off
or so far off that they hit their mic
sorry about that
yeah i guess you know one of the
predominant themes here is just trying
to give players as many
options as possible to really dial in
the experience to suit their personal
tastes right yeah i mean
it is just a set of menus but i'm really
looking forward to hearing people think
of these settings
and the things that they can put
together to customize it to
exactly how they want to be i want halo
to be like the comfiest chair in your
house
i like that all right so let's back out
the setting something else i think we
want to point out to participants in the
tech previews to keep an eye on this
weekend
the news feed wow this is like next gen
news
no seriously um this is just good to
keep an eye on if you're playing in the
tech preview we will probably use this
to convey
updates over the course of the flight
critical information
if the playlist experience evolves we'll
let people know through here right
and i think sam you wanted to
specifically call this one out in
particular right
yeah so we've got a notification for
people on pc especially if you're using
the amd gpu
you're going to want to make sure you
update to the latest driver it is a
significant performance
increase for pc users on amd gpus
so please make sure you do that and make
sure you check out the news for
that kind of attention announcement
awesome
well sam i think that's all i got for
you today any final parting words or
thoughts before we jump over and dig
into some customization
no i want to see the customization too
thanks for having me cool thank you sam
we'll be right back in just a moment
we're going to be joined by jerry hook
here and we're going to talk about
all the things you can do to customize
your spartan in the tech preview be
right back in just a moment
a new day is upon us a new generation
built to fight together
we are unstoppable
are you ready
no scope
killing spree
double kill hello let's do
some damage
skewer acquired
flame the enemy flag return it to base
ordinance drop inbound
the flag is ours
please call us at your earliest
convenience
now show me what you can do
[Music]
and we're back all right thanks everyone
we are back now this is our
halo infinite tech preview preview live
stream here at 343 industries in redmond
washington
my next guest has just sat down next to
me please welcome jerry hook
jerry head of design welcome how you
doing i'm doing great
i'm really looking forward to this uh
it's it's very exciting and we're doing
it live like
this could not be uh
more nerve-wracking than doing it live
just
i probably have like five people
watching no no pressure no stress
mean it's just between us right we're
just playing some halo talking about
halo yeah
um so jerry i think you know you're
going to join us today we're going to
talk a little bit about
sort of the player progression
customization side of the game things
that kind of fall under our live team
umbrella
um kind of from your perspective through
that through that lens
what are you on the team looking for
what are your kind of high level goals
what does this tech preview mean to you
yeah well first let's let's really talk
about what a
live game means to us like we have so
much coming into halo that we've never
had before
we're on more platforms we're on pc
we're
uh we're free to play for the first time
so that means a lot and that has a lot
of changes that go into the fundamentals
and part of what i do is head of design
is help ensure that everyone has
their best work show up in the game and
the
the base fundamentals we use we have
some pillars that we're using to help
make sure that
our players get the best experience
possible and the first one
of those pillars is player first um and
you see that primarily represented in
some of our attributes specifically that
hey look the the time and the money that
you're investing
in our title are extremely important
they're job one for us that's why you
see
us move the battle pass uh to allowing
us to have that battle pass be switched
and then players
aren't feeling the 100 fomo to i got to
get it now right
that's a player first model the other
player first smaller we're looking for
is that our experiences we want to
delight
and we want to have those experiences
you know grow
as we move forward the delight's pretty
key there because we don't want to fall
into some of the traps that you see with
other free-to-play games
where they just add chores or they just
add things that aren't really delighting
the player but the player has to get
through
and so these mentalities change
fundamentally what we're doing from a
halo perspective
next big pillar is we want to we want to
listen we want to learn and we want to
experiment with all of you as as players
and this is critical like sketch you're
such a critical piece of this
of listening to the community and this
everyone out there right now is
screaming about assassinations
and screaming about sprint and
everything else that
all the various community members they
want to have a voice
in the in the hobby that they love and
we're hoping to bring that to you
and you know working with you and your
team sketching uni and
um as well as you know when you look at
tashing you look at our esports
communities
all of them have voices that we want to
make sure that we that we can hear and
bring
into our experiences the next pillar off
of that
is our the story doesn't end with master
chief
the story is actually your story as well
and our story is going to grow
even in the multiplayer side and this is
pretty critical when you take a look at
what tom french and the team have done
with academy and all the other stories
that they're bringing to play
that's your story in in our universe and
we want to make sure that this you have
a story that continues with you
and then lastly it's just for the team
you see so many stories
of game development teams being burned
out and burned to a crisp
and we want to make sure that you know
our core pillar
of we want to be able to build a
sustainable and predictable
uh game for all of you and that that's
really really critical because if the
team isn't there and the team isn't
supporting
all of the experiences we want to bring
bring to you then you won't have those
experiences
and so we have to do it in a very
predictable fashion the other thing from
a player first perspective
our players should be able to trust us
that when we say hey we're going to go
after
you know you you know i've seen like the
list on reddit and whatnot right and
those lists are huge
right and we obviously can't solve all
of them on day one
in our launch we're gonna launch and we
know that we're gonna we
probably made some mistakes you're not
gonna like from uh from
from all of you and we're gonna need to
correct some of those and some of those
you're like hey can you make it bigger
we want to go
go after those as well so that's all
pretty critical
and so in this tech preview which isn't
a beta
is you know we're testing the technical
side of it and so
your purchase everything if you're in
the technical the technical preview
just go purchase everything we need to
test all of our services and connecting
with our
our commerce engines and our commerce
services
and you know joaquin and our service
team are just
man they're on they're on point they're
amazing uh
and we just need to make sure that all
the technology works but we will have
some customization
yeah and it's definitely not a full
customization at all of what will be in
the in the in the launch product
but that customization is going to help
uh at least
help us understand what's important to
you from the small subset that we're
giving you to play with
well i think we should take a look at
some of that speaking of speaking about
my custom spartans
i did want to just clarify one point
you're talking about spend as much as
you can buy everything
just to clarify everyone invited to this
tech pre will be granted uh a bunch of
credits so
we're not asking anyone to spend your
real money so yeah no not at all we
won't even take your money there's no
way to do that so but we're going to
give you
our money and ask you to spend and just
go have fun and remember
prices aren't fun none of that is final
we're just trying to get
you know some semblance of differences
so you as players would know what you
know what's what's better value what's
what's lower value well let's um let's
go back into the build here
josh i guess we'll go to my screen if
you will and i'm going to go into the
customize
the customize menu here up at the top
jerry i thought we might just kind of
run through a few of these things and
then
uh we'll kind of just navigate through
the the world of customization
as it exists in this build which as you
already know it is just a subset of what
we can expect to find in the shipping
game so
i think we'll just go down the list here
people are probably very eager i assume
they've never seen this by the way
i do like this idle animation you let it
sit and just kind of cycles through some
really cool
uh sort of 3d assets yeah which is nice
the other cool thing is like you just
pop into customization you already know
we're doing a
a lot more and you know it's great to
hear sam and you notice some of the
customization that's going on with bots
um and in your own hands with well uh
you know with your
uh ar uh that's all that's all in the
game
uh for for people to play with all right
well let's start by going in the armor
hall and then we're just gonna kind of
quickly move through here and then we'll
you know we'll kind of bounce around
like you and i discuss so armor hall
pretty self-explanatory this is what i'm
going to customize my spartan's armor
right so
um right away here we go um now for this
tech preview
because it's a subset i'm going to have
one armor core and that's going to be my
mark 7 armor core and you know jerry you
and i have discussed this a little bit
just there's been a lot of questions i
think in the community since we first
started talking about armor cores right
and we've we've
demonstrated this and sort of showed it
off in our old overview video and some
prior blogs
so how would you sort of best describe
like what is an armor core and sort of
how should we think about that
yeah so this is one of our new our new
systems so christopher blum
and jeremy have done a really great job
here
uh creating this system you know one of
the things when we step back and design
we wanted to
wanted to rethink how do we help make
sure that our players
uh are really represented as characters
when you take a look
at spartan armor it's like strapping on
an f-22
or maybe you want a set of armor that is
like an m1 abrams tank
right each one of those vehicles is
unique and has a unique character
um the other great thing about that the
the thing we're trying to build is we're
trying to make sure that the character
of that armor
really comes through um there's really
no better way to show this than
um hey josh you have uh
one of the pictures one of the concept
pictures yeah
okay so everyone saw at the end of that
amazing multiplayer trailer the
the samurai armor when we talk about
strapping on a piece of armor as a
unique character
i think i think our first fracture core
and that's we call these fractures
because they're they're not part of the
main cannon they're part of
basically side universes uh that you can
that you can look at
you can look at how we're trying to
develop the character and our artists
have done an amazing job of really
trying to represent
the breadth of what we want to look at
maintaining the character
uh throughout the entire armor set and
more importantly
allowing that customization and you as a
player saying hey look when i strap
on that's armor you know that samurai uh
armor tank
i want to make sure that i can make it
mine and this is the breath
in which we can we can really express
but stay within the character we don't
want everyone to feel like they're just
all one part of a single
uh a single vehicle basically and so
then you can look at
what what what the artists have been
able to
think about and you take a look at the
attachments that you're seeing there
you're seeing swords you're seeing you
know a bandolier you're seeing grenades
you're seeing
different hip pieces you're seeing
daggers you're seeing darts you're
seeing
a whole different expression of what a
samurai could look at
could look like and that's that's pretty
critical for us
to help at least in this first
impression and our first moment
for everyone at launch um because
remember at a live game perspective
we are expecting everyone to provide
feedback what works what doesn't works
what do you want to see more
and that's where the grant game will
grow as we move forward yeah
this is awesome by the way i'm super
excited by the uh roy samurai in
particular which by the way we've also
confirmed will be
um one of the first free pieces of
content that players can earn
in season one by just completing a free
event yeah
absolutely and and again that that type
of completion where
just playing the game and earning things
is still a part of not only our dna but
again
from a free-to-play game we want to make
sure that
we provide multiple avenues not just the
battle pass but you have different ways
and we'll show that
um as as we go forward different ways in
which you can earn things
yeah right now i'm just kind of cycling
through the weapon bench just to give
uh you know give our viewers a sense of
what that looks like so you know if i
were to equip
uh weapon coatings i could check them
out here um i'm just sort of scrolling
through giving people a chance to see
some of the some of the weapons that
they uh we have in the game currently
that they'll be able to check out so
i really love this feature this is so
sweet because every time you pick up a
weapon
right you take it off the weapon pad it
is your weapon
and it'll be skinned the way you want it
to it it'll it'll look the way you want
it to
it is it is just a sweet sweet um
feeling let's quickly jump in the
vehicle bay i mean one big quick caveat
here is none of the experiences in this
tech preview build will let you
uh drive vehicles this time around but
of course vehicles are an integral part
of our sandbox huge part of the
experience especially with the return of
big team battle
yeah so we're going to get to that a
little bit later this year but i'll just
kind of give people a quick glimpse here
um of some of the updated models some of
these things we're seeing for the first
time i believe yeah and again for the
what we're showing here from a
customization perspective
you make this you so you're you get to
say hey look no when i drive my warthog
or when i get on my razor back with my
team i'm the driver
i get into it first it's going to look
the way that that
that i want it to look like and so as
you continue to play
and you're in the community you're going
to have different looks from
from players and everyone will know like
it is you
in the driver's seat all right then i'm
going to jump down one more real quick
here in the body and ai
um this one you know we we obviously
have a couple different body types i can
choose choose from
i'm really i really love actually the
the depth that we've been able to go to
now for prosthetics right just an
additional layer of customization and
frankly inclusivity as well
yeah sure i mean the biggest thing is
just about you know from a philosophy
perspective for
for player first is we want everyone to
be able to represent themselves
um you know my sisters actually does
build prosthetics for a living
and this is very important is it's a
part of your identity um
it's also quite frankly some of it's
really cool
um and again we're only showing a very
small subset so don't get lost in that
um but the sheer fact that you can do
your your entire body the way you want
to from a product
prosthetic perspective and really make
this your identity is really
really critical for us so personal ai is
another new addition to the game we
introduced this uh people heard uh some
personal ai in the mp
trailer for example i know there's a lot
of people out there that became instant
fans of lumu for example
um and i think you know we'll talk more
about this probably with tom french in a
bit and we'll see it in action and some
of our additional footage but
you know it's just a subset right so
there's and it's also just the beginning
like this is the this is the biggest
thing we have so many things in which
you can really express yourself um you
know the way you want to
and even your your ai sidekick
it's yours to express like it's yours to
make yours and i think
the cool thing is like when you see we
see tom talk about it you see the modes
you're going to use it in
it really becomes a part of the
personality that you bring to the field
yeah and you know each each ai here for
example has their own unique voice their
own unique
personality it's really fun and then you
can go one step further if you want to
and actually even
you know a subset of colors as well so
personal ais are one of my favorite
additions to the game apparently and i
can't wait for players to experience
more of that
um and then you know we have one more
grayed out area here and this is where
i'd be able to do stuff like my service
tag and emblem and
you know i think you've alluded to
there's more coming than what's in this
build so we want people to stay tuned
um now i think you know let's quickly i
want to keep things moving here because
i know folks are eager we got a lot to
get through
um how about we you want to jump over to
the battle pass yeah let's see maybe
we'll switch
josh why don't we jump over to jerry
he'll drive us through and let's just
talk a little bit about
um you know what we're designating the
season zero battle pass um
and and sort of what that's going to be
for players in this technical preview
yeah so when you when we take a look at
ourselves learning as a team
reason why we want to do season zero is
like the rest of our live experience
our team needs to build the muscle of of
listening to the players
of providing fixes really going through
even
veteran uh people who've worked on
on games game developers uh when they go
through a service
every game is different every team is
different and
it takes a lot of muscle building to
really get into the rhythm for your
teams to be able to
add to the game and so what we hope to
hear from on the technical preview side
is
again what's working for you what's not
working for you what don't you like
remember the build is old so don't don't
treat it as if it's vinyl at all
um so as we go and go into these details
um just just remember just send us send
us your feedback
give us the details that you want to see
or improve on
and we won't again because we're a few
months from launch we won't necessarily
be able to fix everything for launch but
we'll start adding lists together first
thing i want to talk about from a battle
pass perspective is
is our challenges our challenge system
um
is the cornerstone it is the underlying
thing in which we go now everyone's
familiar with these we've done a little
bit different this is where
you start seeing the first rewards you
get outside of the past
so we know right games are a bit
different today than they were
uh back in the day in fact back in the
day most people only had two to three
games a year that they even looked at
today i bet you most of your steam
libraries are much larger than that
and that means players are going from
sea of thieves
or they're jumping over to age of
empires and then they're coming into
halo as well
and we want to make sure that when you
sit down you don't have to absorb an
entire
battle pass to say what are my rewards
you can literally just
come in what are the challenges i'm
going to go play my games with my
friends
and i'm going to get rewarded for it
that's pretty critical for us from a
player
first perspective and then of course
you're going to get people like me
i'm going to get sometimes get sniper
challenges now
i'm not clutch in any way shape or form
or mickwin or any other protein
i will skip the the that challenge so
i'll definitely probably swap that for
sure
and i'll want to make sure that uh i
don't have to do that because i'm not
good at it at all
so let's look at the battle pass so
we're going to buy this
so what we're going to do yeah we
granted you you're just like a real tech
preview participant
we have given you some money jared all
right good i get paid today
sweet all right
sweet got the pass we're ready to go
so as you can see oh i bought it so now
you can't see the three labels shoot
oh well yeah well you're right but what
what we're not seeing is
a smattering of objects in this pass are
free right so
even if someone doesn't want to opt into
the optional pass in the real game there
will still be a free track and things
are long yeah the main thing you think
of from from a model that we have is
every tier there's a free item and a
premium item and that means that every
single player instead of having
uh you know most systems you have large
swaths
of of the tiers that aren't earned
unless you're premium for us we want you
to earn
every step of the way um and for the
preview
um we're only having 30 level or 20
levels sorry 20 levels in the preview
uh to be able to uh go after and so
uh obviously at launch we'll have much
larger we're not going to talk about
that too much but
the great thing you're seeing here is
you're seeing customization all along
the way
um do you want to go to yours yeah we
can yeah
josh you want to jump back over to mine
because um i had some
development sheets enabled so i've got
everything already unlocked um
actually josh switch back over to
my feed there there we go so now that we
have that context area kind of sort of
where this content is going to come from
i'm back in the armor hall i've just
kind of drilled now into this
this is what happens if i click in on my
core right so
this is we don't need to go through all
this i know folks are probably going to
see some more gameplay we want to talk
about bots in arena as well but
you know this is where i would apply my
coatings for example some of these
coatings i'm going to earn we saw the
keystone coating as a challenge reward
for example
um so this is just a taste of kind of
what i'll be able to do
i can't wait to see how players in the
tech preview i you know i would hope a
lot of people are probably going to
easily hit tier 20 and max out
yeah um you know if not that's our hope
what are you doing you've had this long
to prepare like come on
you've waited for this we need to be
good go crazy but yes this is just to
give you an idea
as i lock unlock my content for the core
this is where i'm going to go in and be
able to be able to customize that
yeah and i mentioned to the other day
but funny fact someone pointed out to me
that
if you want to i think for the first
time in halo game you can have no
shoulder pads which
you know hey if that's your is that's
your fancy go for it
so lots of different options here and uh
and this is like
you're not seeing things in here like
armor effects or
uh other categories that we have listed
here
for the tech preview it's really small
um and so we tried to keep it
basically the baseline pieces um
actually let's talk
about armor kit for a little bit yeah
yeah what is it yeah cause it's just i
don't think this is really
so fully supported in this build though
yeah so when we talk about
um specifically from a pillar
perspective of continuing the story
the armor kit kind of represents a bunch
of that story
and so when you see the season and when
we say story uh we mean the continuing
story of the universe from after you
when you're in campaign as master chief
what are the rest of the spartans doing
you are a spartan and so your story
belongs here too
but it's also a place in which you can
show iconic
uh characters within the halo universe
and so a kit for example
you might get um i don't know george or
emil and that is an entire kit unto
itself
and so you want to like you actually
want to go fly the
you know do your battles on the
battlefield like george
that's where you would go uh to get that
kit
well jerry this is just the tip of the
iceberg
i think there's still a ton of fun
content in here for insiders this
weekend to experiment with
unlock explore i do want to just
reiterate as well
we've said this prior but you know this
is just a test so nothing that people
buy
or unlock during this will carry over to
the final game we're going to wipe the
slate clean
and as jerry noted you know just we're
looking for your feedback we'll have
information on waypoint by the way as
well as in your flight invitation that
lets you know where to go and how to
give that feedback
um and you know the team wanted me to
also just give a shout out and let
people know that
a lot of polish work is still happening
so you know everything from how things
look and are and are presented
we're not done yet so you know i want to
make sure we're given credit to all the
hard work that's still being done and
will continue
up until launch this holiday um jerry
any final parting thoughts or words you
want to leave to us before we jump over
and bring tom in
no i mean enjoy your time and you know
as you said sketch like
this is a few months old um and we have
a long way to go
from where we're at actually today and
what you're seeing
uh but please go test every button
like play everything so that we can make
sure that we have the tech ready for you
uh when when we launch awesome well cool
thanks again jerry
happy to have you here we're taking one
more quick break we're going to bring in
tom french and the multiplayer team
we're going to talk about some bots
we're going to jump in do a weapon drill
or two and talk about the academy
and then we'll take a look at a match
that we recorded on xbox
series x we'll be back in just a moment
a new day is upon us a new
generation built to fight
together we are unstoppable
are you ready
is
hello let's do some damage
[Music]
return it to base
ordinance drop inbound
the flag is ours
[Music]
please call us at your earliest
convenience
now show me what you can do
[Music]
okay welcome back again after that brief
break uh this is still
our hail infinite tech preview live
stream here from redmond washington i'm
sketch
uh and now i want to welcome tom french
tom
welcome associate creative director for
multiplayer how are you it's
it's wonderful to be in this room again
i miss being in this space so it's good
to kind of just hang out i kind of want
to give you a big hug
i know right wonderful it's the closest
just this whole process i haven't come
this close to human beings in a long
time that's a little weird it's a little
weird well it's good to have you here i
feel like this has been i mean this has
literally been years in the making safe
to say uh
yes that is very safe to say well we're
going to talk a little bit about
multiplayer which is obviously sort of
the the key focus for the tech preview
um so much like i've talked to sam and
jerry about thought we might just open
up with kind of giving you a chance to
from your perspective and your team how
are you thinking about the tech preview
kind of what are your goals what would
you like our audience to know from from
your side of things
yeah i mean i think jerry and sam kind
of hit a lot of it on the head really
it's it's the focus isn't
about like kind of fair balanced arena
starts it's really about a tech preview
we need to get a lot of data there's a
lot of
pc data we need to do now that we're not
like just you know
single console focus there's a lot of
information we need to really strengthen
up our back end before we launch this
game
to really just make sure everything's
strong for the fans when we go live
yeah and a lot of work obviously still
happening we've kind of covered that now
you know i think we've got a couple i
think safe to say we have sort of two
signature content sort of buckets
features if you will with this tech
preview right we've got
an academy experience which i think
we're going to talk about here first and
then we're going to move on to bots from
that so
let's start by the academy we teased
this a little bit
i think folks learned about it for the
first time in our overview video last
month
um so from your perspective you know
what's the academy all about
where did it come from what's the idea
behind it i'm really proud of the
academy concept
when we started the journey to you know
what was gonna become halo infinite we
needed uh
i don't know if you know this but when
you go to play multiplayer it's
intimidating to a lot of people and so
we needed to kind of create a ramp for
how players get there and kind of
smooth that out along the way and so we
thought about like what are the
obstacles that players have to do and so
the academy is broken into like three
core parts and then kind of a fourth
extension to that but the first part of
the tutorial where we teach you the
fundamentals of the game uh
we'll introduce you to the kind of the
canon around the mp spartan what is the
player spartan's purpose in the greater
universe
and then the next step after that we
have weapon drills which we'll get to
play with and talk about today which is
cool
and those are really about kind of just
giving you a chance to put your hands on
a gun
in very simple settings really just kind
of mono focused right and just really
focus on how that gun performs and learn
and there's different skill levels which
we'll get to see a little bit
and then the third part is the what we
call the training mode which lets you
play a cat
arena matches basically arena slayer
inside of all of our arena maps
and lets you run around and you can
configure the difficulty of the bots you
can configure your loadouts you can
configure
i don't know there's just a bunch of
tuning knobs to let you really kind of
soften the experience and then the next
step i would say beyond that is once you
kind of get comfortable in there is we
have four v-bot matches
um so we have four players let's i mean
halo is a team-centric game and so
we want players to learn how to play
together kind of first and foremost and
you do that against bots before they
kind of go start getting head shots
across the map
well you mentioned weapon drills which
is the sort of the slice of the academy
that we're including in the tech preview
today
i think we should jump into a weapon
drill or two i'm sure our our viewers
would love to check that out firsthand
i mean tom if you're willing i maybe put
you on the spot here i mean
you can see how much i can embarrass
myself i mean you know what why don't we
trade off why don't we each do it right
so
i'm happy to go first josh if you want
you want to jump back over to my
my pov here um i've already kind of
jumped into the academy menu i'm
presented with an
option for weapon drills you know i did
want to point out this is not the
entirety of our sandbox right this is
what's in the flight
it's a slice right so i would expect
more weapon drills so you know
i think i don't know like what fans
would be most interested in seeing i'm
going to guess they probably don't need
to see an ar weapon
right so let's do something a little
more exotic now this is i might do this
because this is my one of my personal
favorite new additions to the game
this thing is a beast uh it sounds
awesome
it feels awesome and real quick tom how
would you want uh viewers to understand
sort of i got three options here for my
for my weapon drill
so there's three tiers of weapon drills
and the basic one is static bots and
they'll just stand there
kind of just let you get the hands on
the gun right shoot the basic targets
and we'll score you on your performance
and kind of give you a grade so you
understand how where you're using with
that gun
the next here they're kind of on more
just like kind of simple paths or
crouching behind cover and things like
that to kind of show you how to use the
weapon
get you to move that next here how do
you track a target across the screen
and then the third tier is more they
actually are doing combat behaviors
they're not firing back at you but
they're running around and they're
ducking and they're
they're a lot less predictable and so
they're kind of harder to track they're
kind of using more of the actual bot
behaviors and mentality so
i guess i'll split the difference and go
uh i'll go like a tier two okay right
i mean don't judge let's see how you
score don't judge a lot of pressure here
and i mean safe to say has been a lot of
internal trash talking as well right
yeah we trash talk a lot
especially about scores like i mean you
know we're a competitive team at our
course that's what you have to do
you know and speaking of too i think
there is a cool com not only is this a
learning module
in a lot of ways but there is a
competitive angle to it and you know i
think
safe to say down the road the team's
thinking about the possibility of things
like leaderboards and kind of how do we
really
bring that gamification competitive
element to this yeah that was something
that we really wanted in the core design
and just you know it just didn't
fit into the schedule so we're just
building the this kind of as a platform
for how we can add more over time
okay here we go not doing good by the
way that's something our fans notice
right there we have damage per
uh sort of location specific uh visual
indicators on damage right
yeah it's actually it's really helpful
right you can it really helps just that
pop where your head look at that i
already i choked right there now are you
are you uh
are you a feather the trigger person
with this weapon or do you just sort of
pray and spray i'll just be honest i'm
hot garbage with this gun that's that's
first and foremost my problem
um i'm trying to get better with it i i
kind of use it as a like an automatic
but when i'm kind of at range i'll
switch to kind of
the feathering oh man that killer got
anyway that wasn't that was not a great
performance
i mean terrible i think there is a bonus
for like a quick reaction right like if
i were to quickly zoom in on the target
right when it appears i think i might
get an extra i think there's extra
little bonus points and little twists
around it so
all right i want to put you on the spot
now we're going to switch over to your
point of view so you
so first of all okay going for the
controller right because we support
mouse and keyboard or controller doesn't
matter controller guy
whatever suits your fancy tom i am
hearing from our uh our friends over
here in the room that it sounds like
chat
is unsurprisingly very interested in
seeing the vr
uh you know i think that's expected
we'll let's bring up the br then
let's see how i mean i'm okay with it i
do like where you're going with the more
exotic weapons so so maybe we just kind
of break the rules and squeeze into
third grade we'll squeeze in another one
um i'll i'll try to go the the third
tier so people can see kind of the
different behaviors and so you see they
were kind of more bouncing targets than
what you were doing
um so you'll see this they should take a
little more cover and stuff but yeah
obviously a fan favorite weapon um i'm
really nervous how well i'm going to
score
let's see well at least we're picking
different weapons so we're not really
like we can't really compare each other
against
against each other right so
yeah people are already making fun of me
in the stream i can see it
i imagine at least i'm really terrible
about managing my reloads i'm like an
incessant reloader
that's either probably shouldn't
reloaded right there
well when we're missing shots like you
and i do it it makes it a little hard to
be predictable on that right i know i
really feel like it's part of my job to
get better at this and i'm trying
and and i am getting better i'm a little
more better
like btb is kind of my brag
but you can see they're kind of dancing
around a little bit they're strafing
more they're not just
bounce patterns
i'm hitting headshots at least you
almost got this crap reload
time's up i think that's a pretty good
score well it's a new high score
compared to whoever else
so all right so i hit that's tier two so
rank two so yeah so you can see like
we're trying to
kind of give you some grading so you can
understand your skill level and like how
you can get better or you know a little
bit like kind of encouraging to get
better
so you can understand where you're where
you're meeting all right i think
i think we're getting the request let's
maybe like at least one more uh
you want to play one more since you're
already in why don't you do i mean i'll
do it so
i'm hearing that there's a lot of
interest in the heatwave this is uh i
don't think we've really seen or shown
this really to date so this is obviously
new and exciting
a little bit unconventional right a
little bit different yeah it's different
i mean it has an alt-fire which is cool
it's something that's kind of new to
halo
i know queen and his team is really
proud of that and kind of how do we
introducing this kind of concept into
the game and how can we can use this
kind of more in the game
this weapon's really fun and the the two
alt modes or the two modes are basically
vertical and horizontal fire
um i can't remember how this drill
performs so
so the see one of the things cool about
the drills um is a lot of they're trying
to do behaviors that actually encourage
you to
use the weapon correctly so like the
these two
were bouncing near each other and so you
can get a more optimal like kind of
horizontal shot
and i know folks notice it's pretty
nuanced there but i think you're using
your left trigger to sort of swap
between those two
all right get together boys and this
will penetrate right so you can line
guys up and just take them all
very cool last shot suck there we go oh
i'm definitely not managing my reload i
feel like i have more time in the game
right like when you're in a match like
hide behind cover but this is definitely
that like kind of stressful
which is in a good way like it helps you
get better by
you know going through the repetitions
and the drills well the world watching
doesn't probably yeah it doesn't help
i think i'm more nervous about you just
giving me [ __ ] after oops ah we're fine
that's all right we ran the esrb we're
good we're good
mate can't help it content may not be
suitable for all audiences like it's you
man
you're sandbagging us here three star
you're a master
so maybe we haven't seen those scores
yet so we're not going to go through
every weapon drill but you know when the
when the tech build goes out tomorrow
um the weapon drills will be available
right away so you
folks that are in the in the flight can
play until their hearts content all
weekend long we encourage you to do that
and
i want to see people kind of see if you
can be tom's score there you go let's
throw the gauntlet out yeah please i
mean
please beat my score
[Laughter]
if you don't i'll be disappointed so um
tom obviously you know we talked a
little bit about bots as it relates to
the
academy experience that we just saw here
but bots is kind of the other signature
experience as part of the tech preview
so
before we get into the specifics there
bots are brand new to halo like
what do you want the world to know about
bots what's cool about them why are you
excited about them
i'm really excited about bots because
again like playing
multiplayer and halo is a scary thing
and so it gives players like
we have this kind of notion of safe and
being able to play safe and offline in
the training mode and things like that
and so
um having bots to really reflect kind of
player behaviors is a big goal of ours
and so actually our bots don't cheat
they actually
they're i'm really proud of the work our
bots team has done they really are
emulating
player behaviors they're doing things
like watching the motion tracker they're
listening for footsteps
they'll like prenate in areas you get
into the better bots and things like
that so there actually are kind of
reflecting player behaviors back into
the game for you to even
if you're a learning player you can kind
of oh it did that that's something i can
learn as a tool but
again really just giving players safe
place to experiment and learn and warm
up like we found out you know the
community was like
when we first started talking about
they're like oh i can warm up before a
match and stuff like that and
that was absolutely part of the intent
and we see we do it actually internally
are watching our pro team do it as well
so
yeah they are they're they're no
slouches either i can i can say i mean
let's let's talk about that for a minute
we know we've mentioned this a little
bit in our blog last week but
you know my understanding is we want to
kind of ease people into the experience
this weekend so they'll be able to jump
online
and i think sort of it's our second
second lowest skill level bots to start
with right
yeah we have uh we in the game we'll
have four different tiers of bots
there's um
there's recruit and then there's marine
there's odst and spartan and like uh
we're going to start with the the marine
level which is basically kind of like a
silver level player
and then we have the odst which are more
like a gold and then
um the spartan is yeah you know
i'm losing my words right now uh but
they are obviously the higher difficulty
level they're
but we're trying to get like really just
they're the pla level player duh i don't
know i'm
thinking that but yeah so we're trying
to just really kind of ramp it up we
want to let players learn play against
the different spots so we can see the
different kind of
how players perform against them we know
they're not you know they're not going
to like
they're not shotsy they're not going to
like just dong on you like immediately
even when we get to our highest level
they really are a warm up and
a learning tool inside of the game yeah
and i think you know my understanding is
too that
we we want to get focused testing and
data and sort of feedback on each of
those
but sort of bot let you just mention the
bot sort of skill level so
if for example we get enough engagement
and the collective community slays
enough bots
after we go live on thursday my
understanding is okay cool you guys have
passed phase one now right so
then we're gonna kick off and escalate
and sort of raise the difficulty up and
introduce the odst
bots so our hope and expectation is that
everyone out there is playing so much
we're getting all the data that we need
and we're just going to keep ratcheting
it up with the goal of let's hope by
sunday we've got spartanbots out there
and we'll really see
how how some players can stack up to
that and i believe we're also going to
kind of gradually introduce maps in a
similar fashion so the big message there
i think for tech preview participants is
we need you to play a lot and come back
every day because we're going to
try to keep that experience evolving and
keep it fresh um i also wanted to shout
out that we're going to be keeping an
eye on our stats on the back end
and looking to do a little celebratory
shout outs on the halo twitter account
so each day we're going to be looking
for which player has slayed the most
bots
who's won the most games and also i
think kind of interesting
which team has been able to get 50
slaves and win their game against spots
the fastest
and what's really cool in a twist here
we're going to track all that we'll
shout you out on our social channels but
when this game launches this holiday
we're going to capture your gamer tags
now and be able to grant you'll be the
first ever recipients of our one of our
sort of
exclusive emblems uh sorry name plates
rather for
the fire unicorn which has been sort of
something that we've had throughout
throughout halo 5 a little bit in mcc as
well so
pretty cool we're able to kind of start
that muscle now a little bit
yeah so bragging rights high stakes slay
a lot of bots play a lot
but don't slouch because these these
bots mean business especially by time
they get to sunday
um so tom the last thing i kind of
wanted to switch into as well
speaking of evolving experience we're
thinking about possibly turning on
some classic slayer arena i believe as
well at the end of the weekend correct
yes i mean i think yeah the intent is
we're gonna start with live fire uh
with the map which is one of our arena
maps and then we'll we'll go into
recharge or we'll add recharge and then
we'll add mombasa or not mobasa
bizarre which is set in mombasa uh
actually i really want people
especially our fans to really look
around that map there's some kind of uh
nerdy lore things in there that are
super cool but yeah then they
at the end the intent is at the very end
it will um you know we can unlock
basically a chance to play some 4v4
there's a bug in there right now where
sometimes you won't match it four before
you can get a 3v4 match
uh we should backfill somebody into that
match hopefully generally within a
minute or so it depends on obviously
matchmaking and population times at that
point
but yeah that so it should balance out
again it it's not going to give you that
full fair
like core competitive halo start but it
will give
players at least the first chance at
like hands on stick to kind of
you know put sights on another player
for sure and i just kind of wanted to
re-emphasize like our really our number
one priority is is the bot
experience and it's getting all the data
that involves because i don't think we
mentioned this but
even just from the dedicated servers
perspective a bot match
kind of taxes the servers and uses
resources differently than a traditional
pvp match right so it is important to us
that we load test that yeah the bots are
actually
i mean they're running on the servers
and so they're actually putting weight
on the servers and then it actually
it literally because it's four v4 four
players versus four bots
you're kind of you're going to spin up
twice as many servers and so kind of
testing scale and stuff like that
as long as we hit these gates and sort
of checkpoints over the course of each
day
we could have quite a bit of uh fun here
at the end of sunday night but i did
want to reiterate what tom pointed out
we are aware the experience
does have some rough edges um but you
know as long as you're willing to sort
of put up with that we'd love to jump in
and be able to have that fun with you as
well so
um tom i think the last thing that we
have we're going to jump into here in a
minute is
our we have one more gameplay footage we
have a full match we recorded before we
do that though i have a couple of the
things i think i just want to rattle off
one
split screen comes up a lot it's a big
part of the halo multiplayer experience
i did just want to call out that that is
not supported in the tech preview
it is still something that you know is
important to multiplayer for launch
obviously but in the tech preview it's
it's not will not be supported so i
think honestly
i believe you could even split screen in
with your buddy on your couch but then
you can't load into the playlist
together so i just wanted to call that
out in case in case
folks get stuck in that situation um
something else that i just thought while
you're here we could just chat about i
could ask you
folks started asking this question as we
showed off some of our mp content last
month and they're obviously going to
sort of get the experience firsthand
starting tomorrow
and that's about assassinations you know
we saw a couple moments in the trailer
where we saw some
clutch back smacks that probably would
have been an assassination
um so you know folks have asked us are
they in are they out what's going on
with assassinations
so what's what's the scoop there so
they're not in for launch and i think
we're just gonna be straight about that
right like we actually really love
assassinations and uh i remember being
at an hcs tournament with quinn del hoyo
our sandbox lead
uh right when i took my gig and um we
were watching a match
and uh somebody went to backsmack
somebody and they had assassinations
enabled on accident because they turned
them off right
and they got this amazing assassination
it was a super hype moment in the crowd
but you know what happens at a lot of
levels is people just turn them off
because
you know there's a gameplay disadvantage
of it and so one of the things we really
wanted to do is
take a step back and how do we think
about how do these fit into the infinite
gameplay loops and so one of the things
that queen and i keep talking about is
like when we bring them back we want
them to be back
and fit right into our sandbox in the
loops of the game and and bring them
back in a way that really just feels
meaningful so they're always an
accessible tool
but also kind of a flourish moment that
people have yeah so you know we talk
about this a lot launches on the
beginning
jerry alluded to kind of what it means
to be a live service and those
opportunities that it brings
this is a perfect example of something
that i know is already on the team's
radar and i i can't wait to it's
something to look forward to and i can't
wait to see how bots involved and
eventually sorry assassination
possible evolve too right you're right
getting assassinated by uh by a recruit
bot would be an
i think you have to you have to resign
at that point at that point i think we
delete your profile at that point
so i think uh one more thing we want to
show today you know i know people have
still been clamoring for like we just
want to see a full match just show us
the match end to end so we have that
here today we're going to do that right
now
just to kind of tee this up i believe
this was recorded last week or so
this is xbox series x gameplay just
directly out of the console
these are not bots in play this is a 4v4
slayer
on live fire i think a few members of
our pro team
mixed in with a couple members of the
studio at large
i mean you know kind of to your point
right now for this focus this is not
we're not trying to sort of say
telegraph this is the competitive side
of our game exactly so this is about
social it's about fun it's about
learning and kind of evolving so no one
should read too much into that right
yeah i mean this is not your you know
your br starts really curated level this
is this is kind of more
the what like we call internally like
our pub experience or a non-ranked
experience and so this is more of the
quick play option that people will be
seeing
well let's roll that josh if you got it
ready and uh you know
tom if you want to kind of we can kind
of provide some commentary along the way
we're not going to try to cast this or
anything i'm sure folks are just eager
to soak it in
bravo to yell at me later if i it's
about seven eight minutes i think in the
end but this is a full match
of 4v4 slayer halo infinite in our tech
preview
essentially version of this build um on
live fire so josh go ahead and roll that
when you're ready
yeah i think this is a it's a protein
pov
uh well let's see how good they are
right off the bat down from there he's
got the gateway right he's got t switch
to hurt
double kill that's there's night sir
it's good to have steiner back or we
can't there's some nickname of steinsee
is kind of the
the people implementing the vo they
threw down a shield covered the position
yeah i like that little peak technique i
haven't i haven't personally done that
to be honest
yeah i feel like i learned a lot by
watching this protein video actually and
how to play it like we watch them we
have
regular weekly play tests with them i
don't play with them generally because
they just
they're so good and we have we put our
kind of better players up against them
also notice that player went straight
for the power weapon that spawns on this
map in slayer which is
um hard for me to use if i'm being
honest
you'll see like i mean so you can see
the friend foe that's one of the obvious
things you're looking at here now sam
was talking about it earlier
it's something that we've continued to
kind of iterate and evolve even beyond
this build
i think this all this might be our main
build right now
um there's power weapon spawns there
skewer is uh it's satisfying as heck but
it's it's hard for me i'm i'm i am
worst at that gun than i am at the
commando rifle for sure when you hit a
target like especially a vehicle it's
super satisfying
all right so he was spectating
he missed the news
hard for us to hear in studio but i i
believe there you're hearing some
personal ai coming through
yeah you're hearing there's a few things
so we there's the spartan chatter that
we had in halo 5 really just kind of
brings the battlefield gives a lot more
like reaction
feedback what's going on in the game but
you'll hear this personal ai and what we
did with them is
we replaced what was called spartan
leader our team leader um
and they are it's just a more personal
version of that and they have a lot of
personality and so it lets you kind of
swap around and kind of
customize that feedback and they give
you a lot of low level they pulled the
power up
yeah i was just gonna mention you know
that's a different a change right it
doesn't activate on pickup anymore you
can hold on to it
yeah we think that'll bring a lot uh in
the long term and allow us to do more
things with power ups than kind of just
you know
traditional kind of just quick stack
kind of reflections but having like
really the notion of power equipment in
the game
one thing that we won't see from as in
this point of view i really love the
visual language that
you and the team have introduced it's
very obvious when someone's pocketing
a power-up like that you'll see a
glowing trail there's like a contrail
behind them yeah that was a big thing is
making sure we at least telegraph that
information
that was you know making that switch
there was a lot of critical lenses on
making sure that there was at least a
readability to it in the gameplay
i mean so now it's sort of that risk
reward right do i do i hold this and
wait for that final push
do i burn it now so i don't lose it yeah
you make a lot of choices
that way like i sometimes will pocket it
and think i'm getting cocky and then
i'll lose it and i'll give like
overshadow that was a dope
i'll give the os to the enemy which is
you know super risky at that point
we're seeing a couple of little sort of
what do we call those tutorial tips
popping up there which
you can turn off in the center yeah you
can turn them off but on the their death
tips is what we call them but yeah
giving a little bit of feedback you know
about the type of weapon that killed you
or like how you can respond better to it
i'm not sure at this point the pro team
needs to needs to know that like hey
yeah exactly like just opt out if you
don't really care about it if you don't
need that information or it makes you
feel bad
some people might feel
in my sights i do love this map yeah the
pelicans flying by it's the you know
it's
an homage to sergeant johnson sergeant
avery johnson academy of
um so it's kind of cool just to kind of
pay homage to like you know
one of ours and everybody's favorite
character in the set of the halo canon
by the way
whoever this player is is just getting
getting active camo every spot
i don't know what the other team's up to
right now seems to be uh
watching that call out yeah we the
power-ups we treat those like you know
like the power weapons and stuff they're
up on a pad they have a lot of messaging
and broadcasting about them so you know
when they're coming up
yeah you're sparting the ai to tell you
that right yeah the spartan ai calls it
out as well
there's a lot of information just kind
of driving feedback
and get the stick there
you can see like he'll look like there's
the weapon racks you'll see in the
levels as well
he ran past one second
yeah right in the background right yeah
what's cool about them is like you know
before you might run
past where a weapon would spawn and then
not realize that it's coming up in two
seconds and it could change your choice
and like how you deal with it like when
we play test this morning i actually
stopped at one point
on a rash because i was like oh it's
like two seconds out i might as well
wait for it and switch out my pistol
which i'm
i think i'm just telling everybody that
i'm really bad with a lot of the guns in
our game
watch
i do love the sidekick and yeah
it's really cool and like when
somebody's really good with it it's
really threatening because they can just
feather that thing super fast this
player really likes this little like uh
drop wall
kind of yeah
like kind of locking down an entryway so
they can watch their backs
it's neat to watch how people use these
like all the different equipments in
different ways
well hopefully a lot of players this
weekend are going to be uh lighting us
up on social
sharing clips with us because i can't
wait to see just some of the new
creative ways that
the community at large figures out how
to use this new sandbox
yeah and it's interesting too like i
mean like the way we have our maps tuned
like in our main builds
is they have different equipment and
stuff on them and because we don't have
the entire sandbox and the flights as we
swap
things out so it's actually not even the
same kind of basically
map placement path that we would have in
the the release version of the game
but we you know it just at least gives
us something so we can get something in
there for people to play with
oh match is getting close you can hear
the music starting to kick up kind of
signifying the end of the match as well
i do i do love that the multiplayer
music very cool
i'm really proud of the multiplayer
music there's a cool story about how we
got to
basically getting the music in the game
um but it really meets this tone it's
something i've really wanted since halo
4
was this kind of post rock soundtrack to
the multiplayer well actually just a
halo that
became one of my goals for multiplayer
last kill
five minutes remaining
there we go cool yeah that was actually
me playing oh my god nicely done
nicely done hey so i'm happy that we
were able to show that today
not only kind of our first time showing
the game on xbox series x but
we know the community's just been just
show us a full match end to end so happy
we're able to do that you'll be able to
see a lot more of that
obviously firsthand this weekend and i
think safe to say
once we get a little further down and
we're ready to talk more about the
competitive side and some of the ranked
settings
um we know people are probably eager to
see uh i would love to see a true 4v4
pro team match
we'll bring that later tom any kind of
final words or parting thoughts you'd
like to share
before we wrap this up today i mean
mainly i'm just really excited to
finally get to put this game in people's
hands and even though it's just a tech
preview
you get to at least touch the game you
get to run around you get to experiment
with the sandbox you get to help us
you know be part of our team in a way
and then you know just help us kind of
keep building towards the next flight so
we get to launch
yep it's been a long time coming we're
super excited i'll be playing all
weekend as well we'll be online playing
watching
um you know just wanted to go through a
couple quick things right after this
broadcast is over if you want to head to
halowaypoint.com we have an updated blog
that'll go out that'll kind of recap
the official play times that we
recommend for the for the flight
experience for people who are involved
you can take a close look at some of our
known issues and just kind of get a
better sense of what you can expect this
weekend
i also just wanted to mention that we're
also going to be fighting our
next version of halo waypoint so on app
and web
we call it waypoint v next here
internally that actually will be
included in this tech preview
really cool work happening there to help
really extend my
in-game experience out beyond the game
to web and app but you can sort of
experiment with your customization
challenges
that functionality will be working
during the flight encourage folks to
check that out as well
and as a reminder if you want to be a
part of this and an opportunity to play
uh future tech previews and flights of
this nature
head to haloinsider.com sign up please
make sure your profile is complete that
includes
we need you to verify your email and we
need you to make sure you pick which
platform you want to flight on one or
both and if it's pc
we also need you to upload a dx diag
file all the information you need and
all the steps are clearly outlined just
go to hillinsider.com
because next time we're going to go
bigger we need even more people we've
got to go larger scale
because we still have a couple steps to
go between now and launch this holiday
and lastly just want to say thank you to
everyone clearly the community we really
appreciate your feedback your passion
through the years
we know you've been eagerly awaiting
this moment as much as we have the
insider group in particular
huge part of our mcc project to bring
that game update it improve it bring it
over to pc
that wouldn't have happened without the
halo insider feedback and fighting
program
and we can't wait to bring that same
passion and that same just devotion
and desire to make the best game
possible to infinite so i want to thank
you in advance of your time this weekend
being a part of this tech preview and
that's all we got
so share us your clips online head to
hello appointment for more information
and uh we'll see you soon thanks for
watching